hey there everybody we are live for
today's ask a career coach my name is
Martin McGovern and I'm so excited to
chat with you today hear your questions
and see what we can do to help you
succeed in your job search so we're
gonna be waiting a couple of minutes
right now for everyone to join and I
look forward to having the questions
pour in and and diving in deep so if
you're here right now give a shout in
the comments about where you're joining
from in the world what time is it by you
I'm in Chicago right now it's about 2
p.m. Central Time and if you have
questions start adding them to the chat
Rua is gonna be there feeding questions
to me so we can dig deep and really
figure out what it is that it's on your
mind and how we can overcome it our main
question today our topic for the day is
practicing for the informational
interview so we're gonna kick off the
discussion by chatting a little bit
about you know best practices things you
can do we released a video this morning
which gave it a bit of a tip and I'll
dive into that in just a minute but
please thank you so much for joining us
it looks like we're we're getting into
the 30s we've got people coming in from
all over the world here we've got turkey
we've got India
we've got London Arizona Egypt Bangla
tour while we've got folks coming in
from all over the globe 1:30 a.m. in
India Bravo
I know Bravo that is amazing 10 p.m. in
Egypt New York City welcome thanks for
joining us from the coast greetings from
New Orleans who love New Orleans awesome
again we're
give it a couple of minutes for folks to
join the call if you know folks who are
searching for a job right now shoot them
a text shoot him a message
a gchat whatever it is a slack let them
know that this career chats happening
and vitamins so that they can ask their
questions as well and we can all help
each other achieve our job search goals
all right Ruiz in the comments she's
asking you to drop your questions in the
chat so please do that we'll be getting
to as many questions as we possibly can
over the next hour whoo Texas how you
doing welcome
all right when we get to the five minute
mark I'm going to jump into our first
topic of the day which is going to be
how do you practice for the behavioral
interview oh but we got a question
coming in what is a behavioral interview
so maybe we'll start with that one just
a couple more minutes start dropping
your questions in the chat if you've got
them
all right cool we're breaking for tea
let's see how many more folks join us
for the chat today and for those of you
who are just getting here today we are
going to be diving into the ask a career
coach session we're going to be
discussing at first the topic of
behavioral interviews and then we'll
expand it out to whatever it is that's
on the community's mind today so thank
you so much for joining us I appreciate
you taking out time in your day to learn
to grow to become better at the job
search because it is a skill set in and
of itself and if you can master it you
can always find amazing jobs and enhance
your career throughout your life
all right thank you for sharing the link
out to some other folks looks like we
might be bringing in some people from
some other some other groups that'll be
great
we've got some more folks from India
well we got some great questions Thank
You Nima I'm excited to get to that one
okay we're about five minutes into the
call here so I'm gonna get started and
I'm gonna start with Camille's question
the very first one here what is a
behavioral interview guess it's the most
fitting way to start before me just
jumping into my tie right so there we go
a behavioral interview is the more
social part of the interview process if
you're a developer there's two types of
interviews there's the behavioral
interview and the technical interview
technically there's three kinds of
interviews if you're doing informational
interviews while networking but that is
pre job offer or pre interview series so
it's more of a networking thing so what
is a behavioral interview a behavioral
interview is the interview that that you
go into you talk to between one and a
handful of different people who work at
the company and you're assessed to see
if you are a culture fit if you have the
right background and if you are just
generally aware of what this role is and
know and and and to see if you can
adequately explain how to bring value to
this role so that's that's very
different than the technical interview
the technical interview is the tech is
the technical interview is assessing
your tech skills and acumen and it could
include whiteboarding code challenges
and other things of that sort
they're not asking you questions about
who you are what your interests are what
your previous work was they're giving
you an assignment and trying to see how
quickly or how accurately you can you
can accomplish it and what your thought
process is as you're going through it so
that's the difference between the
behavioral and the technical interview
for most people who aren't programmers
you know people in marketing and
different things like that
the behavioral interview is the main
interview there's there might be a
series of behavioral interviews that get
more and more senior so you might have a
behavioral phone interview then a
behavioral in-person interview then a
series of in-person interviews who knows
and it's different in every company but
what you're trying to do in a behavioral
interview is build rapport with the
person you're talking to explain the
parts of your work history that are
relevant to this conversation today and
then be able to by the end of it explain
why you can bring value to this role and
why it would be good for you and them to
work together the biggest mistake people
make in a behavioral interview is making
it too much about themselves you know so
almost every single behavioral interview
is gonna start with the question tell me
about yourself now it's not really a
question it's a statement but how do you
answer it most people answer it by
saying I was born in 1900 habla and my
entire life I've been doing X Y & Z
right and they just go piece by piece
linearly in a linear fashion throughout
their life their life story this is
actually not the best way to answer that
question the best way to answer that
question is to explain what led you to
applying for this job what in your work
history inspired you to enter into this
industry to find this position and why
are we here talking today and we're here
talking today because your company has a
problem has an issue as a need I have a
skillset I'd love to find a way for us
to collaborate together so that my
skillset can alleviate the need you have
or solve the problem that's going on in
your company now most people they just
say you know I grew up in Pennsylvania
and I went to school for this and my
first job was that and my second job was
this and you just bore the person you
don't really ever get to the point of
why is this relevant to the person
you're talking to
so that's really what a behavioral
interview is all about not just
explaining who you are but why you're
there and why you can bring value to the
job at hand so as your thing
behavioral interviews that's really what
you want to be thinking about what do I
need to bring to a behavioral interview
James asks what do I need to bring to a
behavioral interview thank you so much
James excited for this question all
right what do you need to bring I
actually had an interesting question
about this last week I believe in this
series but might have been somewhere
else but someone had asked if they
should bring in a computer and show
their work like pull up their projects
and show their work now I'm not
necessarily saying don't do that because
maybe bring in an iPad in your padfolio
is a good idea and if they ask like new
questions about a project that you've
built you say you know I'd be happy to
pull that up if you're interested in
looking at it and we can walk through it
together that would be a pretty cool
thing I know people that worked in
advertising years ago used to bring in
big pad folios of paper and all the
different examples of the ads that they
made so it wouldn't necessarily be a bad
thing to bring in examples of your work
or at least have them handy if they were
requested but you know everyone has
Google everyone has a computer now so
hopefully they've done their research
and have at least looked at some of your
online profiles before the interview
what you don't want to do is run in and
just give them your computer and be like
here's my computer I'm gonna start
talking about things you want to build a
rapport build a conversation before
jumping into that and then you want to
ask them if it's something that they're
interested in rather than just saying
you know rather than just hijacking the
conversation in showing an example so
again when it comes to behavioral
interview what should you bring well you
should bring to a behavioral interview
is yourself you should dress slightly
nicer than what the culture of the
company is so they're jeans and hoodies
wear jeans and a nice shirt a
button-down or something if they're
business casual wear a suit if they're
jeans and a button-down wear business
casual just try and think a little bit
nicer than what everyone else is at the
company so you need to bring yourself
you need to look professional you need
to bring your resume with you as well as
your cover letter if you have one for
that company
bring a couple of copies of those so you
can pass them out if people ask forum
bring your business cards in case as
something to leave behind bring a pen
bring scratch paper something we'll get
into in a little bit is I like to
practice behavioral interviews into a
voice recorder so I can listen to my
answers on the way to the interview I
have them fresh in my head so that might
be something you bring your phone and
such and then bring questions to ask you
want to bring your curiosity to a
behavioral interview at the end of every
behavioral interview they'll open it up
for you to ask questions now if you're
really good at interviewing you'll be
asking questions throughout the
interview but at the end you do not want
to end a behavioral interview by saying
actually all my questions are answered
have a good day that makes them think
that you're not really interested in
this job and that you're not really
curious about the industry so bring a
list of maybe 15 or 20 questions which
you can find on the Meuse comm in our
career resources all over the internet
different questions that you can ask
about the company the culture the
industry the person the role all these
different things that you know at the
end of the interview you can say yeah I
brought a whole bunch of questions you
pull out your list you start going down
the list and anything that hasn't been
answered yet that's what you get to ask
and so really important to bring
questions to the interview is the
behavioral interview relevant for
techies shouldn't mute them I'm so bad
at names I apologize please correct me
in the comments of how I should
correctly pronounce your name is the
behavioral interview relevant for
techies yes the behavioral interview is
relevant for techies there is a
technical interview when you aren't
going in for programming roles but there
is also a behavioral interview and foam
screens behavioral interviews all these
things are really really important to
practice for when you're trying to get
the job because you know culture fit and
team dynamics they're all really
important when it comes to building a
team so if you've ever been to any sort
of leadership training
seen anything like that a big thing of
what they try and figure out is how do
we create teams that have enough
diversity on them to bring in good ideas
and get everyone's creativity flowing
but our unified enough that we can
actually accomplish and execute on our
goals and that's it's a fine line to
walk it's something that companies
struggle with you know they have
personality tests they have all sorts of
different things that they try to
administer to make it to make their
ability to put teams together better and
better but it is at the end of the day a
very there's the hard skills and soft
skills it's it's more on the soft skills
side of things and it's it's tough to
put a team together so this is an area
where you need to really take some time
and learn about yourself maybe take a
personality test on sixteen
personalities calm to see if you're an
introvert and extrovert what your
strengths and weaknesses are it's not a
scientific test but it gives you some
great you know English explanations like
very easy to say explanations of your
strengths weaknesses and different
things along those lines so when you get
to an interview you can clearly state
who you are what you're good at and not
try to pretend to be some extra hurt or
something along those lines I think
there's a lot of power in introversion
especially if you're there's it let's
say you go into a company and they
already have five extroverts on the team
and every meeting is just you know all
these people talking over each other
well you can say the value I bring is an
introvert to be the quiet person taking
notes sending out the recap and then
bringing all the ideas together into a
cohesive easy-to-understand
narrative so it is relevant for techies
you're gonna need to build rapport no
matter what so don't think that just
because you put your work up on github
or something like that people will see
it be so impressed and then just bring
you in without talking to you you're
going to have to get through a phone
screen a behavioral interview a
technical interview and then probably a
couple other conversations before you
get the job
all right Nima our next question should
we use a mirror for practicing how can I
practice to avoid feeling isolated and
better simulate a real interview I love
this question because it is exactly tied
to the video that we made earlier today
the video I made earlier today was about
the number one thing you should do to
practice for a behavioral interview and
this was something I learned years ago
recording your voice is something that
people don't much care for it is it's
it's a really strange thing that you
know according to science when we hear
our voice coming from the outside it
sounds more high-pitched because when
we're speaking like how I'm speaking
right now my voice is leaving my mouth
and hitting my ear canal and I'm hearing
it you know externally but I'm also
hearing it internally the vocal
vibrations are going up through my jaw
bone into my ear and vibrating over the
eardrum so because it's going through my
bone structure as well as outside of my
head the voice comes through much deeper
there's more base there's deeper tones
to my voice when I hear myself talk but
when I play this video back this
recording and I am editing it and things
like that my voice is so much higher
pitched then I hear it in my day-to-day
life so it's a little bit odd to listen
to and it's not always the most fun like
people if you record a friend's a
conversation with a friend and then try
and play to them they'll be like I don't
want to hear it I don't want to hear it
but if you can overcome that awkwardness
that that sort of like weird feeling
that you might get hearing your own
voice and you can sit down and you can
like just print out a list of your
favorite interview questions like the
top 30 top 50 and then just point by
point hit record and try and answer to
the best of your ability and then listen
back to your answers you're going to get
so much out of that so the example that
you use sorry so the example that you
use should we use a mirror for
practicing I've done that in my life I
think it's a
think it's a good tool but it's almost
distracting like when you're in an
interview you're not gonna see yourself
because when you see yourself in a
mirror like you know you're like
analyzing your face and your facial
twitches which might be a good thing I
don't think it's bad to like you hear
yourself watch so but once you're done
practicing into a mirror the problem
with it is that you forget what your
answers were so within 24 hours after
going through that list of answers and
answering them all into a mirror you're
like wait what did I say to that one oh
I had such a good story what was that
story shoot I forgot that's that's
what's rough about doing it in front of
a mirror now you can do it in front of a
mirror and record yourself because then
you can go back to that was great story
I'm super glad I thought of that how do
I make it better then you try it again
you answer the question again and and
record yourself again maybe you got rid
of some of the UM some of the like some
of the us you know then you listen to it
again and you improve it again maybe you
get rid of some of the rambles like I'm
you know when I'm doing this Q&A I
ramble much more than when I do the
other videos that I actually prepare and
write and so you you can say okay I was
rambling there I can cut that out next
time I say it or I made a good point
here but I kind of glossed over is how
do I double down on making that point
next time and you do this a dozen times
and you're gonna be way way way ahead of
other people who are applying for the
same job because you are quick you're
you're able to pull these stories out
from your memory because you have them
you've heard them you've not only said
them but you've heard them and then said
them again and heard them there you're
committing it to memory so should you
use a mirror for practicing go for it
should you use an audio recorder to
record yourself and listen back a
hundred percent should you do video I
think that's also a great way to improve
your speaking abilities other things
that I've seen people do go to improv
classes that helps you you know think on
the fly and get used to the anxiety and
things like that how can you practice
and avoid feeling isolated and better
simulate a real interview I know working
with career coaches like myself is
really good
you can actually do mock interviews
there's websites that allow you to do
mock technical interviews but also mock
behavioral interviews so if you're
really trying to figure out how to you
know simulate the situation you might
reach out hire coach or get a friend or
a family member to sit down with you and
just let them ask you questions and then
try to answer them but again record
yourself so you can go back and listen
to it and refine your answers as you go
you don't want to start from scratch
every single time you try to answer a
question all right all right
Shahji what should my elevator what
should be my elevator pitch if i have
transitioned from journalism to
front-end alright what should be my
elevator pitch if I've transitioned from
journalism to front-end this is a great
question so this is a question about
connecting your past to your present and
the cool thing about being yourself is
that the things you've done in the past
and the things you've done in the
present have a link and that link is you
so what are your interests when you
think way way way way back to when you
first got interested in journalism what
was it that interested you was it
telling stories was it creating a
narrative was it helping people
understand things what was the thing
that attracted you to that business in
the first place then you can ask
yourself well why did I make a change
a lot of times people make a change
because they're unhappy they're stressed
out they're burnt out different things
like that not the best tone to bring
into an interview but think about the
positives okay so I was really
interested in telling stories and
helping people learn when I was a
journalist now I'm in front-end
development well what is it about
front-end that I really like is it the
user experience is it the story of
moving through this brand and learning
about it and purchasing a product like a
lot of you know jewelry brands a lot of
clothing brands a lot of different
brands hips have Neher
as a big piece of their business puzzle
so you can make a connection of well I
told stories using journalism and now
I'm telling stories using code and
that's the next evolution of my career
so you're not just running from let's
say burnout or stress you're running
towards the next evolution in your skill
set so first I learned how to write then
I learned how to tell stories then I
became a journalist then I learned how
to code then I learned how to tell
stories with code and now I'm helping
shape people's experiences through
front-end design and how they and how
they engage with purchase from and build
a relationship with the companies that
they'd like to purchase from and
interact with so when you're thinking
about your elevator pitch always think
of it as an evolution of your history so
for instance my backgrounds in marketing
I wanted to get out of like banner
marketing and move into something a
little more creative so I went into
advertising then I wanted to get out of
advertising and move into something that
was more direct to the consumer so I
helped people with their personal brands
it's just marketing at a different level
marketing through a website then
marketing through like commercials then
marketing through one-on-one personal
brand help and now marketing using the
same marketing techniques to help people
build their career create videos share
content it's all in evolution of the
same thing we all have some sort of
thread that ties it all together so you
just have to find that thread and tell
that story and your journalist so you
might be really good at this share in
the comments how you like what story you
end up coming up with and tell us that
story you know let us know it'd be
really interesting to sort of see what
your pitch turns out to look like if you
can share it in comments share it on
LinkedIn send it to us personally I'd
love to take a look and help you refine
it as well make it better so feel free
to reach out
all right
shouldn't be them sorry I'm so bad at
names I've got to learn how to pronounce
names
what role does attitude play in the
behavioral interview attitude attitudes
an interesting word I'm not quite sure
if you're talking about attitude like I
have an attitude like a bad attitude or
if you're talking about it as like I'm a
positive person because I'm a you know
I'm an optimist or a pessimist right I
think there's a difference between you
know trying to be the funds or something
I don't know if you guys know that
reference but pretending you're like hot
stuff right I think being humble and
being very honest about what you can do
what you can't do what you're working on
and what you hope to accomplish in the
future I think that is really important
to have that humility but I also think
that most people downplay their
accomplishments too much when I talk to
people they're like I'm not ready it
says this it says I need that I don't
have that yet so I shouldn't apply we
spent so much time disqualifying
ourselves and telling ourselves no when
in reality you need to just have belief
in yourself if you've come this far if
you've been able to learn if you've been
able to hold a job then you're able to
continue to grow continue to learn and
continue to hold jobs so when it comes
to attitude in the behavioral interview
the attitude you want to show up with is
one of I know what I can do I know that
there's plenty of room for me to learn
and I'm consistently trying to learn on
a daily basis I'm extremely excited and
curious about what's going on with your
company and the way in which my
experience can be brought in to bring
value to what you're trying to
accomplish and I really look forward to
continuing the conversation with you to
see how we can best work together if you
come in with bad attitude a
collaborative confident humble and
forward-looking attitude you're going to
be
just standing out amongst the other
people because most people you know
they're nervous they're playing they're
downplaying their strengths their up
playing some of the things that they're
scared about internally you know and
really at the end of the day if you're
curious and if you want to help you
truly want to help them with their
business not just get a job to make
money you're gonna have the right
attitude and of course you know we all
want a job we all need to make money we
all gotta pay bills but you want to do
that at a company that you at least are
interested in right so if you're
interested in self-driving cars just
because that's cool technology tell them
that if you're interested in it because
you think it's gonna reshape Society
much bigger grander thing tell them that
but don't but don't worry too much about
sorry about that don't worry too much
about you know trying to fake an
attitude just just be genuinely curious
about the things that you're already
curious about I mean you're on this call
so you clearly have things that you're
curious about
so dig into that discover it and then
share it in the interview all right
Massoud
how much does choice of clothing matter
in a behavioral interview this said you
know so much of the job search is so
much of the job search questions so many
of the job search questions that we get
are answered with the word it depends
the phrase it depends because it really
does depend on the company and the
person you're interviewing with
traditionally it was very simple if
you're trying to get any sort of
corporate job you wear a suit if you're
in a white collar job you wear the white
collar I don't know
you know blue collar white collar
whatever it is but Mark Zuckerberg wears
a hoodie and you know billionaires are
wearing business casual the world is a
very confusing place when it comes to
how you should dress for things
I'll give you a little bit of a story
when I was applying for a job at a
startup they flew me out to Boston and I
wore a suit and that suit that I wore
was the only thing I brought with me cuz
I was just getting on a plane I flew out
I was gonna have a day of interviews and
fly back I didn't pack any other clothes
I get there already in the suit I left
it like 5:00 a.m. that morning and they
they're all in like jeans and t-shirts
right so they say hey take the suit off
I'm like you know I can't change into
anything they're like well at least
loosen your tie
I knew that would just feel awkward to
have my tie loose all day going in out
of these interviews and I don't know if
I'm in a suit I just want to be in a
suit I don't want to be half in a suit
so what I what I did instead was I made
a joke about it I said actually my
family has a rule and this is a funny
joke from my family that if you're at a
wedding and there might be a camera
anywhere at the wedding still you never
undo the tie because you always see
those pictures after a wedding with
people in their undershirts and they're
all sweaty and all that stuff but all of
us are still suited up to the max by the
end of the at 5:00 in the morning when
the last pictures are being taken it's a
funny joke it was something like an
inside joke that happened for years and
so then I told that little story and I
was like I will not undo this tie the
whole day that I'm here and so it just
kind of became a little fun banter back
and forth between us they'd be like come
on take that tie off I'll be like no and
I would make it tighter and so those are
fun things that can happen when you have
a clothing snafu like I had and you know
that turned into a role and it was a
really great company really great job
but when it comes to what to wear and
how much it matters I think certain
companies don't care at all a lot of
startups a lot of small businesses
consultancies things like that but there
are also a lot of companies that care a
lot finance things like that you know
older school businesses they really do
care about the look because they want to
have a professional culture so what you
should do is go to their website look at
the images of the people that work at
the company
watch some YouTube videos different
like that to get a feel for the company
if there are any videos out there and
then reach out to people that work there
and ask what the daily dress code is
because then what you can do is just go
a slight bit higher like I mentioned
earlier just do it a little bit better I
made the mistake of they're all in jeans
and t-shirts I'm in a suit I should have
been in like smart casual I think is
what they call it business smart
business something like that where it's
like jeans and a button-down and a
blazer like that would have been perfect
for that role probably even too much to
have a blazer but that's an area where
you know you've gotta sort of feel it
out you you're not gonna wear the same
thing to every interview as a matter of
fact the first time I ever wore khakis
and a blazer to an interview I would
thought I was gonna walk in and get like
laughed out of the room but they all
wore jeans and a t-shirt so I had to
bring my style down my what I was taught
was the right way to do it back into
reality because times changed you know
back in 2010 when I graduated college
you had to wear a suit but you know
three years ago that wasn't necessarily
the case so it does matter and you know
we live in a world where people make
snap judgments based off how you look we
can debate about whether that's good or
bad but it is the truth and so if you
walk into an interview and you're
wearing torn jeans and a t-shirt and
like I don't know sunglasses over your
eyes people are gonna be who is this
person why are they wearing sunglasses
inside you know those kinds of things I
always want to be professional just try
to be professional if you're being
professional and you're curious and
you're excited to be there
it'll show
all right we have a question from mom
who codes hello mom codes I have a 10
year work gap after my bachelor's degree
do I need to mention that do I need to
mention that it's asked tell me about
yourself
I was a stay at home mom how do I
explain that all right so I'm not a
stay-at-home mom so my experience with
this is all anecdotal and as you can see
I've never done that myself so the what
I heard from from my experience chatting
with a bunch of people who have done
this the best thing to do is is to look
at being a stay-at-home mom as a job as
though it's on your resume and so what
you know traditionally people have tried
to do is you know ignore the gaps on
their resume and hope it doesn't come up
what ends up happening there is if
someone finds like sees that gap and
you're trying to cover it up then they
start asking all sorts of other
questions about what you're trying to
cover up and you know there's there's
tons of resources out there that will
explain this much better than I will
and there's organizations you know for
mothers entering back into the workplace
that I definitely think would be good to
look into because they might be able to
introduce you to people in companies
that already have thought about this and
don't care right so some people will
care if some people won't care most
people will understand that being a you
know a stay-at-home parent is a real
hard job at least I understand that and
believe that and what you'll find out is
that if you actually go and talk about
what you did as you know a parent you
know I organize schedules I got people
where they need to be on time I you know
let PTA meetings I whatever the things
might be that you did to organize your
household those are all applicable
skills like all these things that we do
like I even encourage people to talk
about their hobbies as though it's work
experience because if you run an
networking
group on the side it's not a job you're
being paid for but it's something you
should get credit for if you're
organizing people sending out emails
doing different things communication all
these things are skills that will play
into your job so I would try to
integrate it maybe not in the first tell
me about yourself question but you could
maybe drop like a an Easter Egg to it
and say as a stay-at-home mom I have
found that doing X Y & Z always leads to
better results so I try to incorporate
that into my work today as a programmer
something along those lines and help
businesses you know achieve these
results so I would I think that's how I
would approach it if you could put a
little Easter Egg to it in your like
initial elevator pitch and then later it
when they say tell me a little bit about
your work history or something like that
you can say from this period I was
getting a bachelor's degree from this
period I was raising a family and from
this period I was doing internships and
other project work boom you've got
yourself a great story and you're not
downplaying it you're not making excuses
for it and you're not apologizing for it
because you shouldn't have to and so
those are the ways that I think from my
limited experience you could potentially
approach this from like how to market
yourself how to tell your story
but then definitely go seek out some of
those some of those resources that are
you know have spent years and years and
years studying this and helping people
land jobs and overcome those larger gaps
in their and their work history thank
you so much for the question
all right oh boy I'm so we've got some
some names that I am not good at
pronouncing yet so I'm gonna give it a
shot but I really apologize I'm gonna
butcher everyone's name today
Abdul gawe how should I approach
answering the interview question of what
are your current areas of weakness I
love this question thank you so much for
sharing it there's a lot of stuff online
about this well people will say say
something that's actually a strength
like oh I'm too sometimes I'm too much
of a perfectionist or something like
that I don't know I think people are
starting to see through all that and
it's like the humble brag is a weird
thing it's a weird phenomenon to me I to
just be very honest about certain things
and and I'm always trying to learn and
grow so it's not hard for me to say like
yeah this is an area that I'm not
naturally good at so things I'm
naturally good at I really enjoy
marketing I really enjoy selling things
creating logos being creative coming up
with ideas helping people structure
their ideas and execute on their goals
but what I'm bad at you know there's a
lot of different things I'm not good at
you know sharing the things that I've
created and the things that I've learned
with other people so that they can learn
from it and apply to their work I tend
to finish a thing move on and never come
back
so reporting I'm not so great at
reporting the outcomes of things I just
tend to move on to the next project
and so that's something that I've been
called out on throughout my career and
something that as I work my manager will
have to come up with some sort of plan
together in order to make sure that I
don't forget to do that and so that's
sort of how I would answer a question
like that right it's like that is always
going to be a struggle for me so here's
how I would hope to work
with my manager too you know mitigate it
right I need their help it's almost like
saying it's not fully within my control
and it's not perfect at this point so I
need a little bit of help in that area
and then I can help other people with my
strengths and so a good place to start
for this and this might be my takeaway
from today's QA altogether but go to WWE
nella T's dot-com it's a myers-briggs
type of a personality test and they'll
give you like I'm an infj or different
things like that and it breaks here
personally down into four parts but
aside from what personality gives you
and whether it's right or not because
it's not super scientific but what I
love about it is you can say oh wow
these are the parts that I agree with
and these are the parts that I disagree
with and it gives you some very clear
language to use if ever you want to talk
about things like strengths and
weaknesses so if I were to go there and
I can actually just pull it up right now
16 personality is um and I'm an infj
so an infj is an advocate that's their
personality type I've taken the test so
I just I'm gonna scroll down to
strengths and weaknesses they actually
have strengths and weaknesses here and
my strengths and weaknesses are
strengths
creative insightful inspiring and
convincing decisive determined and
passionate altruistic and they give
paragraph descriptions of each one of
those things so if someone ever asked me
that in an interview I can literally
answer the question by saying I took a
personality test and this is what it
says my strengths and weaknesses are or
this is one strength in one weakness I
pulled from the test that I agree with
and that I'm working on you could also
quote black you know managers and you
could also quote feedback you've gotten
from people in the past that's another
good way then trying to invent it
yourself I think that's the main thing
I'm sure don't try to invent things try
and pull it from reality you pull it
from examples that you've seen in your
life and so if we went down to my to my
weaknesses
my weaknesses are I'm sensitive I'm
extremely private I'm a perfectionist I
always need to have a cause I can burn
out easily burn out it's a big one I
burnt out a lot of times in my life and
I can reference those things and I can
talk about the meditation practice I'm
attempting to incorporate into my life
in order to overcome burnout now I'm not
very good at meditating I've only done
it twice this week
but I'm trying like those are things
that I'm trying to do and this is a
weakness for me so those are the things
that I think you can talk about and
resources that you can use to really
answer that question in a positive way
all right these are awesome questions
and we got a bunch here I'm going to try
and get there as many as I can in the
color Akbar Ava how would I answer the
question why do you want to work with us
assuming I have very little information
about the company this is a really
interesting question and the reason I
find it so interesting is how do you get
to the interview part of the job search
without knowing any information about
the company that's the thing that I
think we really need to you know dig
into a little bit on this question if
you're chatting with the company and
you're all all the way at the interview
portion you should have done a lot of
research and had a lot of conversations
like what research did you do to fill
out your cover letter to tailor your
resume what were the things that led you
to this role how did you find it what
were you you know was it just something
that fell in your lap or did you
actually seek it out if you really don't
have any information about the company
my first thing would be to go find some
information watch youtube videos listen
to podcasts if the founders and CEOs
have any podcast read their website read
blogs about them put on the news alert
on Google there's all sorts of things
that you can do to get some research on
this company right and then from that
research ask questions when you're in
the interview but you should really know
why you want to work with them and let's
say you don't know much about the
company specifically but you're
interested in the industry talk about
that say well this company makes
individual parts that are used in
autonomous driving systems so they make
the parts for the cars that are that
drive themselves well you want to work
with this company because it's really
important for our future and the in the
future of this industry of electric auto
auto driving cars to succeed because you
you are so excited about a world in
which no one has to drive
accidents plummet and people are more
safe and less people get into automobile
accidents overall net in the world you
like this company because they
manufacture the parts then enable the
cars that prevent the deaths right I
actually you know worked with someone
and they said in their LinkedIn profile
my goal is to eliminate all human
drivers they can do that with a hundred
different companies who are all working
towards that goal now that's a pretty
extreme goal and it sounds a little
strange but what they're saying is that
they want a world where it is safe to be
on the roads because no humans are
involved it's all just machines moving
seamlessly so that's a way that you can
start to think about how to answer the
question about why do you want to work
with us but the truth of the matter is
if you don't know why you want to work
with that company by the time you get to
the interview it's gonna be a weird
interview because they're gonna ask you
all sorts of questions about the type of
work you do the things you want to
accomplish where you want to be in five
years and if you don't really want to be
at that company you're gonna have a hard
time convincing them and selling them
that you're right for the job so do a
little bit more research and really
figure out why you want to be there
that's I mean that's the only way to
answer that question is to really know
why you want to be there so for instance
Udacity is trying to change the future
of education I think education is too
expensive overall net in the world and I
think the more people that can get
educated the better so it's a really
cool mission I'm supporting it so I were
here if anyone else is working with a
company right now or has a company in
mind that they really really want to
work for in the comments share your
reasoning why do you want to work at
that company and it shouldn't just be
because they're a big name and I want
that big name on my resume it should be
because you know let's say voice search
is gonna be the next big thing in your
mind and you want to be working at
Amazon or Google working on that
technology so you can usher in a world
where we don't have to interact with
devices we just have to talk and things
happen around us sounds pretty cool to
me so really take a second think about
it if you if you have one to share in
the comments please put them in
all right Massoud how much should I
smile how many times and what are the
appropriate situations when it is
considered acceptable I love this
question thank you so much for sharing
it how much should I smile how many
times there is no there's no ant there's
no number that can be placed on this
this question so like I couldn't say
like in an interview smile every three
seconds so it's like hey my name is
Martin and I really am enjoying talking
you all and it's gonna be awkward so how
much should you smile and how many times
I don't know I tend to be grinning all
the time people like to see you smile I
don't know maybe I'm not maybe I'll go
back and watch this video and realize
that I never smile who knows I think if
you are asking good questions and giving
well-thought-out answers the amount with
which you smile doesn't matter so much
it's cuz you're thinking and you know
when we think we're not usually like you
know thinking off in the distance we're
like hmm that's the sort of interesting
thing that I'm thinking about so I would
smile when you say hello when you shake
their hand when the conversation is
starting but when you get into a
conversation when you're you know you
should feel as though the hope is that
we get to a point where you're talking
as though you're talking to a friend or
a mentor or someone who you trust right
and so we're not necessarily going to
just be grinning the whole time it's not
like a first date where we're like
uh-huh uh-huh everything you say is
hilarious it's it's one of those things
where we're trying to just connect we're
trying to share information understand
the needs and and bring value and so you
know smile when you say hello smile when
you say goodbye
if funny things come up smile like don't
I just think the main thing here is
don't overthink it if you're
trying to focus on your body language
and smiling and all those things you're
gonna lose track of the answers that
you're trying to give to their questions
so focus on the answers to the questions
first and then hopefully you're like you
know getting really into the answers so
you'll naturally smile and be expressive
I think where we get a little bit stuck
is if we're like you know seeming
uninterested or is so monotone that they
don't think that we're excited so you
want to show some excitement you want to
talk about the things that you've done
with like oh and then we did this and we
were so I think energy is more important
than smiling per se and gosh I think I
had another thing to say but I'm
blanking on it yeah try try to just
bring energy into an interview rather
than worrying about the smiles and if
you're a low energy person who's more
introverted that's fine don't feel like
you know you're gonna mess up the
interview just because you're
introverted but at some point during the
interview if you're just monotone the
whole time try and pick up the
conversation little try and inject a
little bit of saying that maybe you
can't hold it for an entire hour but you
can maybe do a few bursts throughout so
they can see your energy and it'll just
suppose against you know the basic you
know introverted tone and it'll show
that you you light up when you are
interested in certain things so thank
you for that question I think it's I
think it's a really interesting one
because it is the kind of stuff that
goes through our heads as we're trying
to prepare for these interviews it's
like Oh what do I dress how do I sit how
do I talk how do I smile it's
nerve-wracking and it'll you'll just get
better as you do it over time
one thing I was talking to someone about
recently was mimicking and mirroring
people said not mimicking sorry one
thing I was talking about was mirroring
people so if they're leaned in it's good
to lean in if they're lean back it's
good to lean back if they cross their
leg cross your leg that's a weird like
psychological thing that makes people
feel comfortable when they're talking to
you if you're stay
being over someone while they're sitting
it's awkward but if you're both sitting
it's a little bit more comfortable if
you're both sitting the same way it's
even more comfortable so those are some
things to keep in mind and then I'm
gonna add on to this eye contact when it
comes to eye contact people say just
make eye contact and it's very
disconcerting when someone is just
staring at you in the eyes and you start
getting a little like oh my gosh they're
staring at me so one thing you want to
do it's called Kennedy eyes this song
that John F Kennedy US president did he
he would make people feel instantly at
ease like they'd known him forever
because he would look at one eye than
the other than the forehead and the nose
and then randomized that so his eyes
were constantly moving around their face
rather than just staring at their pupils
and what that does is it makes someone
feel like they're not being like a you
know stared at or like attacked they
just feel like oh this person is someone
because if you just think about in
normal conversations you're looking over
you looking at your watch you're looking
all over the room you're looking at them
but you're like half paying attention
sometimes like you don't want to half
pay attention in an interview but you do
want to make them feel at ease and and
Kennedy eyes is one of those things that
may or may not help or sorry that may
help you it's actually something I used
to practice I would look look look look
count to three count to three so I feel
you on this how much should I smile
thing but I was a massive introvert but
I was a massive introvert and that was
what I had to do to overcome these these
anxieties and these fears and now I
don't think about it at all but it's
something that I think might be very
helpful for you
all right got a little lifts in ten
minutes I'm gonna try and get through as
many as I can
oh boy we have so many great questions
here thank you all for sharing I hope to
get to these in our future Q&A s but
we're just not going to get to them all
today
all right so there's two questions here
and I'm going to trying to answer the
first one is from was Seif and the next
one is from Anastasia the first question
is how to best answer the question give
an example of how you handled a major
crisis or how do you handle stress I
usually have little or nothing to share
about it and I go blank and the second
question is how should I answer this in
an interview if I don't have such good
experience
tell me of time and you worked in a
group project alright so there's two
pieces to this the first one is it's it
is very likely that at some point in
your life you've worked in a group
project so you really have to dig deep
and think in my education in my
volunteer work in my family in my paid
work when was a time that I worked in a
group and then ask yourself like even if
it's just your group of friends trying
to plan a vacation or an outing
you know I'm typically the person who
shows up to the group of friends and
they've already said we want to go to
this place we want to go camping in this
in this part of the country at this park
at this thing and I just go awesome
let's go let's go have fun I don't
really care where we go I don't really
care you know although I'm not too
nuanced about like the specifics of it
but I'm always the person that will add
on and then bring something to the group
so how do we make it fun while we're
hiking how do we make it how do we find
the voodoo donuts place that's nearby
the campsites so we can have bacon
doughnuts or something like those are
the kinds of things that when you're
thinking about how you act in a group
you know that's typically how I bring
value I'm more of a collaborator right I
bring additional things to it and so the
weirdest example is like an escape room
I've done an escape room with a couple
groups of people and you can pull some
you know some inferences from there of
how you might work in a group so first
really dig in and try to think of
obscure examples of groups you might
have been a part of
and then try and relate that story that
specific story to the interview so I
might even say in the interview I'm the
person that brings the bacon doughnuts
and that applies to this job because if
we're working on a group project
together I'm gonna be bringing in
resources I'm gonna be bringing in new
ideas and then I'm gonna be
collaborating with people to turn those
ideas into action items and then I go
execute so I don't necessarily you know
form the initial plan but I take the
plan and turn it into next steps and
those are things that that potentially
could be the way you talk about it when
it comes to managing handling a major
crisis and handling stress I find it
hard to believe that you've never been
stressed out in your life so the
question would then be at what point
were you the most stressed out and what
did you do about it
I know that the points of my life Brow's
the most stressed out I get very
organized I typically am you know I I'm
organized
probably more so than some people but
not like every detail of every hour of
every day but when I was in like my last
sort of high-stress crisis mode what I
did was I actually planned out every
minute of every day I knew exactly what
I was doing I tracked my time and I was
making sure that I was accomplishing the
things that I was going to accomplish so
the way that I respond to stress is by
over planning let's say so that's one
thing that you can do is dig into your
life what were the times of your stress
maybe not at work but maybe outside of
work and so with all of these examples
of how to answer questions what you
really want to do is find a specific
example and then just tell that story
what happened why were you stressed how
did you overcome it where you had today
what was the time you were in a group
how did you act and how does that affect
you today if you can get to if you can
get a specific story for each of those
answers you're golden but if you try to
be vague if you're trying to say well in
general here's how I am you know handle
stress I'm never going to be able to
picture you in the scenario or if you
say in general this is how I act in a
group I won't be able to picture you
with your friends eating the donut right
you want to be specific so they can
see in their head what you can do and if
you can do that you'll stand out so
awesome questions thank you so much take
the time to sit down and try and write
out a few stories pull some questions
from those lists of top interview
questions and try and write a few
stories down of a time where you were
really stressed out and you you might
find two or three stories pick the one
that's most relatable the most that had
the best outcome and utilize that in
your in your job search all right we're
coming to the end here so I'm gonna
start wrapping up thank you all for your
questions please bring these questions
back again next Thursday if you ask them
right at the beginning I will I will get
to them and I'm really excited to
continue to dig into these questions
every week with you and make sure that
we're helping you move forward in your
job search
RSVP really is going to put the links
below in the or put the links in the
chat so RSVP for our next session it
will be next Thursday and then also if
you could give us a little bit of
feedback we would greatly appreciate it
she's gonna share the type form in the
chat click on that and just let us know
how we're doing what we can do to
improve these videos and how we can make
this entire exchange better for you so
you can achieve your career goals my
name again is Martin there's my voice
cracking my name again is Martin
McGovern I'm super excited to see where
you take all this information next and
what you end up doing in your search
reach out to us any time and let us know
how things are going and we will
continue to bring you as much career
information tips questions QAS and all
that stuff to help you move forward
thanks again have a good one